welcome to date of his death talk I'm
your host - Ghazi our today's guest is
Ben Collins Ben is a freelance data
analyst developer visualizer and founder
of the Collin school of data is also a
Google developer expert let's get
started welcome to the show thank you
miss I think you mean
also a little bit about yourself what
got you interested in spreadsheets and
stripping in the first place
sure so after college I went into the
finance world and I would see that my
bread and butter then is spread chic so
I'm spending all day with data in
spreadsheets with formulas and gradually
just became more and more comfortable
with the formulas world and it's a
little bit like a rabbit hole the deeper
you get into it the more you discover
and and so the formulas became sort of
let's find out how I can make these
formulas more efficient and make my work
better and then that led into the world
of scripting and saying okay this is
really interesting how can I oughta make
these processes I'm doing an extend
power of the spreadsheets and my work so
that was my first foray with
spreadsheets and that was sort of
started 15 years ago that journey I
guess and then sort of in 2010 ish I
came across
G suite and the Google sheets world and
made that step across into G suite and
Google sheets and found out script
pretty soon after that so I could
continue a journey of learning and you
know getting more from my spreadsheets
so I have to ask you this girl vlookup
or Enix that's a good question and I've
got feet in both camp I'd say because I
think that the vlookup is a great one
when you just need to do something quick
and easy it works it's great somebody
know-how who's it and then the index
match gives you a lot more flexibility
it seems to be the question that divides
the spreadsheet world into and I know
that my old office we had we had camps
in both
we're advocates for both and they were
previous advocates for for each but I
think that I would say learn both you
know go and do the vlookups and then and
then really it's not too difficult the
jump across and learning next match and
that then eye opens up tons more
opportunities you know with what you can
do with index and the match both
separately under together so let's say
I'm an analyst and I don't know anything
about app script why is it important for
me and how do I get started so let's say
every week you create a report and you
apply the same formatting you create the
same chart you do a little bit of
preparation with your data and each week
it's the same and you're sort of
spending 15 minutes half an hour an hour
doing this pretty repetitive process
then that's a great contender for
automation and that's what scripts allow
you to do so you know with just a few
lines of code you could transform some
data and then a few more lines of code
you can create the chart and that's the
power of apps could be write that once
and then each week compressor and a
voltage to do those steps for you so a
great way to get started actually is to
use the macro recorder and what that is
is a built-in feature in the UI so in
the actual spreadsheet itself well you
can press a big red button do your thing
which is sort of add some formatting
create the chart process your data and
then press stop and and that the macro
recorder turns that into code in the
script editor editor which you can then
just go and run when you want to repeat
the action so that's a great way to get
started and then from there you can open
up the script editor and see exactly the
code that the macro recorder has created
and you'll start to see you know even if
you don't understand it at first you'll
start to recognize sections whether
perhaps you'll see some cell references
and then you'll start to understand a
little bit about how that code is
interacting with the spreadsheets
another way is custom functions so
custom functions are a way for you to
write a little bit of app script to do
something that's completely you
unique to your to your workflow so you
might create a function that uses Google
Maps to to work out the distance between
two points and that you can just use
that function then just in your Google
sheets without needing to keep rewriting
code or going to external get to the
maps and doing that separately and then
copying pasting it back in sort of
things so it's a lot of time sleeping
switching gears how did you get started
with data studio so I remember back in
2016 I I was doing all the lot of work
with this with Google sheets and and
then up pops onto the radar this new
tool coming from Google that's a
business intelligence tool for the Self
Serve in other words something that
you're gonna be able to use yourself to
create these visualizations and reports
and it's are super interested because
I'd worked in the space for long time
now and so I'm always sort of interested
in new tools and and especially ones
that will extend the capabilities of
what I'm doing with the tools I have
right now and so yeah I was super
insulated jumped on it
I've got evolved with the beta program
and collaborated with you on some
feedback and write some blog post
recording some videos and that's sort of
how that started for me one question I
often hear from folks is that you can
always build graphs and charts in
spreadsheets and we can share that what
is the benefit of having a dedicated
business intelligence tool or reporting
tool like data studio that's a great
question and I think one of the
principal benefits is first of all it's
very simple and easy to use to create
very professional looking reports so
with a spreadsheet it's a little bit
more work to to make it look like a
report or dashboard rather than a
spreadsheet that just has some charts in
and so maybe that's important so that
you're you know your stakeholders look
at the report and take a little more
seriously than just perhaps it's a
thrown together spreadsheet so it makes
you a professional reports very easy
great another huge benefit is it
separates the data from the
visualization by by having a dedicated
report that people interact
interact with with that with the data in
a separate layer that they can't touch
they just make sure that that later is
it's nice and secure you have the unique
capability of looking at this import
analyst point of view and from a
developer wife view
thinking from that angle how do you
think data student view is so you can be
beneficial to small and medium
businesses what it does is it
democratizes data opens up the data to
so many more people and so both building
with a CEO or being given a report and
interacting with then using a report are
both very very intuitive and easy they
have that same interfaces the D Suites
tools so it sort of feels familiar
already and then building natural
Porter's it is really quick and really
easy and so it really lowers that
barrier to entry for people to go and
explore their own data and then also
just using those reports if your report
is shared with you it gives you a lot of
options to interact with the data to
drill down into the data in a very
visual way
I love the demo that you built with the
International Space Station position so
you could see the position of Isis any
point of time at like way it was there
was a little bit about that like how did
you build that sure so it was right
around the time actually that Google was
introducing the the community connectors
which are the connectors so that you can
connect the third-party services with
data to do directly and pull in that
data from another web service in today
to do which is like super cool was
really excited about this and I was
looking around for some examples to just
try this try this out because there was
a couple of examples on the Google's web
sites which I tried and then I thought
you know what I wonder if there's a way
to plot the position I just I sort of
I'm always interested in space stuff I
followed the you know rocky launches and
that kind of stuff so a bit of a space
geek I searched around found an API that
publishes the position of in latitude
longitude of the International Space
Station and thought yeah that's that
let's see if we can make this work and
it was a great first connected to bill
because the authentication was
there were worth there was no
authentications it was it was a nice
simple connector pull in that Latin long
and plus it on the world map you know in
a nice dashboard that had some touches
like a picture and sort of a current
date and things that just to make it
look a little more polished you have
built a number of disconnects waters
like open source and for your clients
what is your workflow look like when
you're trying to build a connector for a
new data set way to start what is your
so I would I always start by spending
some time with that service and it
depends if it's a service that I use
myself obviously I'd be familiar with it
but if it's a client that I'm working
for and it's their service or service
they use then what I like to do is make
sure I go and get a demo account spend
some time with the tool so I know I
understand what the context is and I can
start to understand you know why would
somebody want that data in data studio
and what what are their plans to do with
it I think it's really important that
you have that that context before you
jump in and rush to build the connector
so that you know you know when that data
when you're bringing that data through
that pipeline will where it's going to
end up and what it might look like so I
start with a tool the service spent some
time there next thing is to go and find
any documentation about the API its
present I'm reading there see if there
are any tutorials or guides to just have
a look at and understand and then what I
do is I open up the Google sheet and the
script editor and build all the
connections that API from my Google
sheet list and start putting the data
into Google sheets and the reason I do
that is because I don't need to worry
then about the data studio architecture
yet I can focus purely on the connection
to the API start getting some data back
maybe check the authentication and how
that works and then start passing that
data and making sure that I've got the
API piece all built and sort of
rock-solid then I can open updates to do
and rather the absolute poverty to do
put in the boilerplate build the
plumbing and then plug in that API piece
finally and that's my approach that I
rather than trying to sort of
immediately jump to today to do foil and
so hopefully suffer audience would
benefit from that packard audience can
you share your favorite data store tip
with sure so I was thinking about this a
little bit before I came in today and I
was racking my brain for something super
specific maybe a neat little unique
feature or something and then I sort of
realized that actually my top tip really
is to spend some time learning about the
best practices for data visualization so
knowing the best chart type to use for
the data you have how to make sure that
your dashboard is impactful as possible
because that will have a bigger impact
than sort of focusing too much on the
tiny granular details if you really can
make sure that your native pops of the
page and gets that message across as
efficiently and effectively as possible
then you'll get maximum impact from your
from your dashboards then thanks for
being on the show thank you very much
you can check out Ben's blog and his
courses on its website the link is in
the description for more data studio
content make sure to subscribe to the
GCP channel you can always visit our
website at developers.google.com slash
data studio until next time keep
building more awesome biz
[Music]
[Applause]